bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
coloriage géographie et mathématiques
avec le théorème des quatre couleurs
alors le théorème des quatre couleurs
c'est un de mes théorème préférées
et donc c'est un théorème qui dit que si
vous prenez une carte géographique qui
contient des pays ou des régions
vous pouvez toujours là coloriée en
utilisant seulement quatre couleurs par
exemple ici j'ai pris l'exemple de la
carte des régions françaises et vous
voyez je les coloriés en utilisant
seulement rouge vert jaune et bleu alors
j'ai pris les régions actuelles mais
j'aurais très bien pu prendre les
régions futur ou en fait n'importe
quelle carte ça marche aussi
voilà vous allez me dire bah si on veut
on peut très bien là coloriée en
utilisant une seule couleur oui
évidemment vous pouvez toujours utiliser
une seule couleur
mais si vous faites ça vous violer la
règle fondamentale qui est que quand on
a deux régions ou de pays qui se
touchent
on veut utiliser deux couleurs
différentes sinon on voit pas la
frontière alors en pratique les gens qui
font des cartes il utilise six couleurs
cette couleur voire plus un mais ce que
nous dit ce théorème c'est que on peut
toujours trouver un moyen de colorier en
n'utilisant que quatre couleurs alors
moi la première fois que j'ai entendu
parler de ce théorème je trouve ça un
peu incroyable je le dis à quatre
couleurs c'est pas assez
d'ailleurs un moyen de trouver un contre
exemple il suffit de faire une carte
complètement alambiqué avec des pays
tordu et donc je dois avouer que j'ai
passé quelques cours de philo à jouer
avec mon voisin a essayé de trouver un
contre exemple au théorème des quatre
couleurs
le principe du jeu est simple il y en a
un des deux qui dessine une carte
complètement alambiqué avec des régions
tordus qui se touchent les unes les
autres
il passe la carte à l'autre et l'autre
essaye de la coloriée en utilisant
seulement quatre couleurs et donc s'ils
arrivent à la colorier bas c'est que ce
n'était pas un contre exemple
alors évidemment c'était un jeu
complètement vain puisque je vous ai dit
le théorème des quatre couleurs c'est un
théorème un théorème c'est à dire qu'il
n'a pas contre exemple on sert à rien
d'en chercher un
ce qu'il faut savoir quand même sur ce
théorème sait qui il a un statut
particulier dans le coeur des
mathématiciens
vous savez c'est un théorème qui a l'air
simple on se dit la démonstration elle
peut être facile en fait elle n'est pas
facile du tout les mêmes très difficile
à tel point que les premiers qui ont
réussi à le démontrer c'était seulement
dans les années 70 ils ont dû céder d'un
ordinateur
c'était quelque chose de complètement
nouveau vous savez d'habitude quand on
fait une démonstration en maths bas on
prend son papier son crayon ou alors son
tableau est sacré et puis on écrit son
raisonnement alors des fois ça prend en
trois lignes
des fois ça prend en 300 pages mais à la
fin on peut tout écrire à la main et
bien dans le cas de la démonstration du
théorème des quatre couleurs
il y avait plus de 1900 cas différends à
traiter à la main et les deux qui ont
fait ça s'il avait voulu le faire
vraiment à la main eh ben ils auraient
passé toute leur vie donc qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont tous rentrés
dans un ordinateur et ils ont laissé
l'ordinateur faire la vérification et
quand l'ordinateur a eu fini ils ont
considéré que le théorème était
démontrée et ça ça a causé beaucoup de
débats parmi les mathématiciens parce
que il y en a qui considérait que
utiliser un ordinateur pour faire une
démonstration s'était pas valide comment
on est sûr que le programme tourne
correctement comment on est sûr que
l'ordinateur fait pas d'erreur qui a pas
un bug qui a pas un court-circuit un
problème de mémoire n'importe quoi et
donc ils ont dit non ses démonstrations
là elle n'est pas valide alors depuis ça
a été beaucoup amélioré et on a vraiment
une totale confiance dans la
démonstration du théorème des quatre
couleurs et depuis il ya eu aussi
d'autres théorème qui ont été montrés
par ordinateur mais il reste encore chez
les matheux quelques irréductibles qui
considère que bah non c'est pas des
démonstrations validé il faut continuer
à chercher une démonstration du terme d
kalck couleurs qu'ils puissent se faire
entièrement à la main
alors si malgré ce que je vous ai dit
vous persistez à vouloir vous aussi
essayer de trouver un contre-exemple
hôtel reine des quatre couleurs faut
quand même que vous sachiez qu'il ya
deux conditions pour qu'ils soient
valides la première condition c'est
qu'on veut que les pays ou les régions
ne soient que d'un seul tenant d'un seul
morceau on veut pas par exemple un pays
qui serait coupée en deux morceaux
déconnecter en mathématiques on dit
qu'on veut que les pays soient connexes
vous savez en pratique cette condition
allait à peu près jamais vérifié prenez
simplement l'exemple des îles bas une
île elle est forcément déconnecté du
continent et donc on a une situation
d'un pays qui est en deux morceaux alors
en pratique les il pose pas trop de
problèmes pour quand même colorier avec
quatre couleurs il ya des cas qui sont
un peu plus tordus il ya par exemple un
exemple fameux c'est lé enclave de
kaliningrad enclave de kaliningrad c'est
un petit morceau de la russie qui est
déconnecté de la partie principale de la
russie et qui est coincé entre la
lituanie la mer baltique et la pologne
alors un cas comme l'enclavé de
kaliningrad c'est pas trop trop
problématique on peut quand même
probablement colorier la région avec
seulement quatre couleurs mais si vous
commencez à imaginer que tous les pays
ont des enclaves les uns dans les autres
mais là c'est facile de se convaincre
que le théorème des quatre couleurs
marche plus et en fait d'ailleurs cette
situation là elle existe
parce que si vous réfléchissez bien
c'est exactement ce qui se passe avec
les ambassades
vous savez une ambassade elle fait
partie du territoire national par
exemple l'ambassade d'allemagne à paris
c'est un morceau de l'allemagne donc
avec toutes les ambassades qui a dans
tous les pays en fait on a vraiment
cette situation où tous les pays ont des
enclaves les uns dans les autres et donc
en fait si on voulait colorier aussi les
ambassades avec quatre couleurs ça
suffirait pas alors l'autre conditions à
respecter pour que le théorème des
quatre couleurs soient valides
c'est qu'on ne veut pas que sur notre
carte ya des points où il est plus de
trois pays qui se rencontrent vous savez
un cas ou trois pays se rencontrent
c'est le cas normal quand vous avez deux
frontières bla et trois pays qui se
touche sur un seul point mais par contre
on n'interdit qu'il y ait quatre voire
cinq pays ou plus qui se touchent au
même point c'est assez facile à
comprendre si vous imaginez que vous
avez cinq pays qui se touchent en un
seul point
chaque pays est en contact avec les
quatre autres et donc fatalement il vous
faudra au moins cinq couleurs pour le
colorier alors je me suis demandé si
c'est un genre de situation ça existait
en fait entre les pays alors en fait à
l'heure actuelle
ça n'existe pas mais ça existe et
notamment dans les années 60 en afrique
à un moment donné il y avait une
situation où on avait la zambie le
zimbabwe la namibie et le botswana qui
se touchaient tous les quatre en un seul
point alors ça va pas durer très très
longtemps parce que ça pose est quand
même quelques petits problèmes notamment
si vous avez une situation comme ça ça
veut dire que en principe les gens qui
sont dans le pays du nord peuvent aller
directement dans le pays du sud sans
passé ni par celui de l'est ni par celui
de l'ouest
ce qui pose pas forcément trop trop
problème quand c'est juste des gens mais
ça commence à être des troupes là ça
pose des petits soucis géopolitique est
donc en fait cette situation ne va pas
durer très très longtemps et rapidement
ses revenus à une situation normale où
on avait seulement que trois pays qui se
couchait alors au niveau international
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus mais en
fait on trouve pas mal de cas au niveau
national est un exemple qui est très
connu qui est aux états unis il ya un
endroit où on a quatre états qui se
touchent qui se rencontrent à angle
droit en fait c'est lui talent colorado
l'arizona et le nouveau-mexique et donc
les américains sont même amusés à
construire un petit monument cet endroit
là et dans le sol il y avait une toute
petite plaque qui indique le point exact
où les quatre états se rencontrent et
donc sur la photo vous voyez là le petit
garçon il est dans quatre états
différents à la fois
alors si vous creusez un peu en fait
c'est des cas encore plus tordu le plus
tordu que j'ai trouvé ça se passe autour
de l'etna en sicile en fait autour de
l'etna il ya dix communes différentes et
administrativement en fait ces dix
communes se rencontrent tout au sommet
de l'etna donc ça veut dire que si cette
région vous vouliez la colorier avec des
couleurs différentes pour chaque commune
eh ben vous seriez obligés d'utiliser au
moins dix couleurs et donc ça veut dire
aussi que si vous vous tenez au sommet
de l'etna exactement vous êtes dans dix
communes différentes à la fois
ceci dit je vous déconseille de vous
tenir au sommet de l'etna 1
quand même pour conclure sachez que le
théorème des quatre couleurs n'a
strictement aucun intérêt pratique en
général les gens qui font des cartes
ils sont pas rationnels en nombre de
couleurs non le théorème des quatre
couleurs il intéresse juste les
mathématiciens et puis les gens comme
moi qu'on des théorèmes préférées merci
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo n'oubliez pas
de la partager
aussi aller voir mes vidéos précédentes
vous abonner à la chaîne et me retrouver
sur mon blog sciences étonnante vous
pouvez ensuite me suivre sur facebook et
sur twitter
à bientôt